um
what was uh what was the record that
caught tops attention
do you remember like which record or
what what it was that like yeah that got
you
that meeting with top yeah well better
days is the one that really really
caught
tops attention but the one that made top
feel like yo like this dude can like
make records because
that's top's big thing right now it's
like yeah you can wrap it can you make
can you make records exactly and it was
on there you have it it was called [ __ ]
with me and when he heard that record he
was like
yo like yeah this dude he can go you
know what i mean and it wasn't even
we weren't even supposed to sign like
musa was taking me to him
we were actually supposed to be doing
something with uh with dave gross shout
out to dave gross he would do a lot of
stuff with nip
and we were supposed to be doing like a
little partnership deal with dave and
and dave shows a lot of love and he was
gonna help me build up a little bit
and then the plan was to go to the top
and moose kept listening to the music
that i had and
without me even saying so he just took
it to top and then top was like you know
like let's sit down and have a meeting
and uh i was playing music for like an
hour tops not bobbing his head and
nothing like they not giving me nothing
like he's
showing moose memes and [ __ ] i'm like
some of those disrespectfully
that's
and then [ __ ] with me played and that
was the first time that he kind of like
put his phone down and started bobbing
his head
and so i leave the meeting i'm low-key
like depressed i'm like that [ __ ] did
not go well and moose tells me he's like
no you gotta understand my pops like
if he didn't like it you would you
wouldn't been here for an hour like he
don't he don't do that you know what i
mean he was like so
you know he was like a deal might not
happen today or next month or whatever
but you know like let's just keep
working and go back to dave and regroup
and
we'll come back and then like three days
later moose called me and he was like i
think my pops gonna sign you and i was
just like
what the [ __ ] like this is crazy you
know what i mean so it happened way
faster than i thought
um and you know that was also part of
the reason why i feel like it took a
little longer for me to
drop some stuff after i signed because
me and top still had to get to know each
other
as people you know what i'm saying
because it's such a people label yeah
for sure yeah
yeah so we have to still build that you
know what i mean it's a family business
exactly 100 people forget that like yeah
yeah yeah it's a family business yeah
like top will not sign you if you don't
if you don't personally [ __ ] with you
he'll just take you and get you signed
somewhere else and get a piece of your
contract like
yeah yeah exactly on everything